hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen heute zu einem neuen video
das die belichtung gestürzt ist aber die
sonne ist beschissen tokio sommer hier
wird es schon im titel eingeblendet die
witzigsten musicals ich habe nämlich
einfach mal wieder beim musical i
geschaut einerseits unter dem hashtag
comedy andererseits auch unter anderem
helfen bei leuten die ich schon kenne wo
ich witzig fand habe mich quasi einfach
mal ein paar musicali trost sucht dich
besonders witzig finde und die ich hier
mit euch teilen würde
folgt man beim musical lied heißt da
laser luca steht da eingeblendet gorny
das musical i dass ich euch jetzt als
erstes zeigen möchte ist von einer
person die aus amerika stammt ist eine
frau ich sage das ist eine frau als wenn
das irgendwas schlimmes
jedenfalls finde ich bei ihr ein ultra
krass was die filme mimik habe ich finde
im deutschen raum hat so die miete nur
sein ich es gerade ein vogel da egal was
ist los mit mit mir und den deutschen
youtube oder mimik finde ich nur sagen
des ju und in amerika irgendwie kinder
ausgesprochen
diese leute können einfach gut
schauspielern und ich zeige euch jetzt
ersteres musical delight quasi die ganze
zeit und sagen dann am ende bin ich mir
ja cool ich wollte jetzt kein zweites
oder drittes oder viertes musiker die
von diego und wird rein dem jetzt weil
ich eigentlich augen ganzes video bei
ihrem musical machen könnte die findet
auf jeden fall traviss nicht folgt leser
als sie glaube ich bin da macht er auch
gerade eingeplanten gesehen als ich das
musical gezeigt habe also eincheckt sie
auf jeden fall auch vom musical 7 8
ultra geilen komme dies darf das nächste
musical hits von cameron dallas viele
sagen mir ich sehe genauso aus wie der
finde ich nicht jedenfalls ist das ein
typ von wein der also so kurze sekunden
videos kommen die mäßig macht das hat er
auch bei dieser kelly hochgeladen
diese gehe darum dass seine freundin zu
ihm kommt und er ihr sagt dass bei ihm
nichts geht und darum geht wer immer
diese partie sie sieht derzeit am ende
also dieses typische ok niemand will
diese person bei der party haben
gelabert
nein das musik fand ich einfach meist
und habe ich ihnen die witzigsten
musizieren das video mit reingenommen
werden da dieser typische amerikanische
wein humor ist also wein von der
plattform nicht von dem wein
man kann sicher haben wir die situation
identifizieren jeder das irgendwie schon
mal mitbekommen so eine situation und am
ende fast immer alle so richtig auf das
nächste musical es von selbst südhessen
die glaube ich
wenn ich auf der einen seite ultra süßen
auf der anderen seite megabits sich wie
dieses kleine mädchen da die ganze zeit
tages gegen die jetzt mit den grund
gehen oder am ende noch so mit dem so
tanzen oder sind sie ihren fuß so hoch
und so das ist einfach mega cute oder
auf der anderen seite halten willst ich
weiß aber lustig ist zum kleinen
menschen beim tanzen zuzuschauen also
fand ich auf jeden fall auch mit sechs
junge habe es um ihr fell bekommen
es ist jetzt kein richtiges comedy
musical i sondern halt eigentlich nie zu
dem er seine lippen bewegt also ehre
lipstick klinik hat aber trotzdem
willkommen die schienen mit drin sei
halt einfach dieser typ 3 mit die massen
so die ganze zeit und longboard finde
ich einfach mit dem der macht alles wird
sich also ich feiere dem übel zu seinen
content
hier seht ihr übrigens im hintergrund
nicht mehr nur weiße kisten eingeladen
sondern jetzt auch schwarze kisten
dienst nämlich ab dem 10 10
zusammen mit 1007 stick haben wir also
geht auf jeden fall am 10
luca shop bestellt euch sein kissen dann
bekommt ihr nämlich einen signierten
sticker dazu wenn ihr einen der ersten
1000 bestellungen seien also seid
schneller ihr ensembles aus hatte die
geilste seite und wir machen jetzt
weiter
dieses musical hits von pink ist er
wirklich gesagt dass zusammen mit diesem
pkw stieg ich weiß auch nicht wie der
ausgesprochen geht es auf jeden fall
auch so ein amerikanischer wein menschen
zusammen mit dem du machst es geht dann
sagt darum dass diese zwei leute so ein
bisschen nötig verkleidet sind tobago
spielen und dann so ein youtube sehen
aber daneben stehen da die ganzen hotels
und wann tillich ist hat sich dieser
wein humor das nächste musical ist
wieder von cameron das ist finde ich sie
überhaupt nicht aus wie der er macht
sich in dem musical i heard zum affen er
sitzt nämlich in seinem flugzeug allein
und im team sitzen complete stranger und
er singt da einfach in so ein händler
kassel
finde ich cool weil es einfach zeigen
dass es ihn nicht dass um ihn herum so
viele leute sitzen und das fire assets
die rede ist von den onboard puppets das
ist nämlich einen youtube kanal der ist
aber auch die videos die sie machen wir
sie machen so kurze kommen die videos
wie haben die jetzt auf musical die
hochgeladenen finde ich auch mega geil
ist auch so ein bisschen dieser
amerikanische wein humor ist glaube ich
gemacht von rudi man kusel rudi solltet
ihr auf jeden fall mal raus checken
ich denke einige von euch werden eh
schon kennen berkant übels gut voll
viele instrumente spielen kann singen
und hat den geldbedarf sein humor ist
der beste den ich je gesehen habe ihr
seht schon ich diese ganzen
amerikanischen leute da aber wir schauen
uns etwas musicali annika lohse terminus
co
es geht darum dass diese puppe namens
diego nach hause kommen und wenn wir die
youtube videos kennt weiß von hallen der
fakt sich total aber seine frau und
komplett so nach hause und ich glaube
das hat das musical die auch schon seit
es irgendwie erklärt ich finde diese
ganze dorf ins videos einfach so witzig
das ist wirklich mit case lasse der
einzige kanal die ich selbst und auf
youtube schon deswegen musste ich sie
mit reinnehmen schon was in zukunft sehe
er aber ab und zu was geht da vor
einmal in der woche ein mal im monat ab
diabetiker hat dieses musical i ist von
enya drews heißt sie glaube ich nie
hatte ich ja auch schon mit drin hat
sich musik lief nach gestellt habe und
da sie jetzt kommen die dinge macht war
nicht einfach uns war cool weil sie ihre
lippen darauf perfekt bewegt hat es geht
um gegen seine heidi klum
ernährungstipps verarsche von wegen ja
heidi dafür was süßes essen nein du bist
ist deine ernährung haften darf ich denn
schokolade essen sein das ist das essen
nein ihr habt ja gerade gesehen fand ich
auch chillig winzig und sie hat einfach
perfekt rüber gebracht mit diesem leben
der kamera herr gucken die ganze zeit
das was hier von dem video beide damen
und herren ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen wenn es das getan hat was auf
jeden fall fetten like damit findet ihr
gerade zwei die eingebettet wenn ihr
darauf könnte meinen kanal abonnieren
das kostenlos cool und dann seid ihr
cool und hier findet ihr ein video
eingeblendet wo ich die dümmsten
musicals rausgesucht habe also texas auf
jeden fall
ja